hello my name is Adrian and um today
I'll be talking about unitary property
testing lower bounds by polynomials this
is true at work with my advisor Henry
from Columbia University
and um I will introduce what
um the unitary property testing problem
is and then followed this by the two
main contributions in our paper which
are the generalized polynomial method
and an application of this method to
property testing with one proofs
so the quantum query complexity
um is Central in the study of quantum
computing
and in this model an algorithm queries a
bit of a Boolean string in superposition
in order to compute some function or
property of this string X
and general one wants to come up with an
algorithm that minimizes the number of
queries made to the string X
so what a study Quantum query complexity
firstly it captures many of the known
Quantum algorithms such as a Grover's
search
and the quantum period finding algorithm
which is the basis for the quantum speed
up in a short factoring algorithm
secondly since
um we can actually prove lower bounds
for query complexity unlike in many
other models of computational complexity
this enables a rigorous comparison
between a classical algorithms and
Quantum algorithms for solving a
particular problem
finally uh when we prove able to prove
lower bounds on Quantum query complexity
this provides Insight onto the maximum
possible Quantum advantage that's
possible for a particular problem and
for the rest of this talk we'll be
focusing on Lower accounts
there have been two main paradigms for
proving lower bounds in Quantum
Computing complexity namely the
adversary method and the polynomial
method and we'll be focusing on the
polynomial method in this talk
the polynomial method was introduced in
the paper but eels and others in 2001
and which states the following
observation that given the P which is
the acceptance probability of a t query
phone algorithm on a particular input X
then a p can be expressed as a as a
polynomial of degree at most 2T which is
not too much greater than the original
query complexity
and this implies that if algorithm
computes some function f with a bounded
error
then this polynomial is a good
approximation to the function f and
furthermore it has degree at most 2T
therefore showing that there's no low
degree polynomial approximation for a
particular function f
implies that there is no Quantum
choreographer that uses a small number
of queries for computing that
and this this powerful observation has
been used many times in the quantum
query complexity literature
however
um while this puppet has been very
useful the inputs and outputs are still
classical strings
and not all Realms of interest in
Quantum complexity of theory can be
analyzed in this way
and this is because in general uh an
experimenter could be interested in
studying an arbitrary Quantum system
which is modeled by a unitary operator
you
this being a matrix is quite different
from a classical string
however the standard query model is is
indeed a special case we're defining the
query to a string as a unitary that Maps
the base of state by to plus or minus I
depending on the ice bit of this string
so
um what are some of the examples of
these unitary property testing problems
that aren't captured by the standard
string model
some of these problems might actually
have a reasonable classical analog
for instance
um in the dimension counting problem one
is given access to a unitary
of the form I minus 2p where p is
projector onto a Subspace
and one wants to check if this Subspace
has some Dimension
um less than equal to W or Dimension at
least 2W for some parameter w
um this is
um can be argued to be analogous to the
problem of approximately counting the
Hamming weight of a string which has
been studied in the quantum very
complexity literature and indeed we were
able to leverage these lower bounds in
order to prove a lower bound 100
Dimension counting problem
however we also have other problems that
do not appear to reduce to a natural
possible analog
um the first such example of a problem
that we study is the unitary occurrence
type problem
which is to determine if
um
given a unitary U
H whether or not after T applications of
the Identity or if EC to the t is
Epsilon far away from the identity
Matrix such problems arise in the study
of quantodynamics and Quantum chaos
foreign
testing entanglement properties which is
promised that U is a reflection about
some Quantum state in CD tensor CT we
would like to find some way to estimate
the entanglement entropy of
um
of that state
again entanglement properties and
entanglement entropy are very natural to
study in term in the context of quantum
physics and chemistry
finally um we have the example of
testing hamiltonian properties
which is um you know promised that U is
the time Evolution operator Associated
to some hamiltonian age
uh we like to check properties of the
simultaneous which on the 160 sample
would be to test if it's geometrically
local or not and you know such problems
uh can naturally arise in the context of
quantum experiments in the physics
so it seems as though we require new
techniques to analyze the complexity of
these inherently Quantum problems and uh
we argue that the generalized polynomial
method is is one such way to to analyze
these problems
from the perspective of computer science
and complexity Theory but unitary
property testing problems are also
interesting since there is a connection
between uh query lower bounds and Oracle
separations of complexity classes
for instance the grover search lower
bound
leads to an opera leads to an oracle
separation between the complexity
classes bqp and and theme
and um
query lower balance on unitary property
testing problems
similarly lead to Oracle separations
between Quantum complexity classes
this idea was already used by under
erinson cooperberg to give an oracle
separation between the classes qcma and
qma
and if we propose an approach using
unitary property testing for an oracle
separation between qma and qma2 we will
revisit this towards the end of the talk
so now that we've given some examples of
unitary property testing problems and
um you know argued why
um they're interesting to study
um we know the state
are generalized polynomial method that
we use to analyze these these questions
so
we firstly show that
um if we have a t query one algorithm
that's able to query some unknown
unitary U and its inverse
then the acceptance probability can be
expressed as
a degree of 2T polynomial in The Matrix
entries of this unknown unitary U
and furthermore this uh polynomial has
some nice properties such as it is a
software joint polynomial
however this observation alone is not
very useful for local balance this
polynomial that we get is a
multivariable polynomial and in general
it is is very hard to improve lower
bounds on on such problem units usually
at the lower bound techniques or degree
work best when there's a small number of
variables
however we can observe that we can
exploit the symmetries of your unitary
property testing problem to reduce the
number of variables and thereby approved
lower bounds
um we show how we do this for the
recurrence time problem that we
introduced
So You observe that this property is
actually a unitarily inverting property
that is if a unitary U satisfies the yes
condition or the no condition of the
problem so does
um v u v conjugate
for any unitary V
in particular this shows that we're not
U satisfies the property
depends only on the eigenvalues of U
so we exploit this
um
symmetry
to show that
the acceptance probability for
um
any T query algorithm
for the current step problem is not only
a
a polynomial in the
um the Matrix entries of U in fact it is
a very special problem it's kind of
polynomial
in fact it can be written as a little as
a degree at most 2T polynomial
in the eigenvalues of U that is also a
symmetric polynomial
and more generally
um this applies for any uh unitarily
invariant property
so this observation
um
is um quite interesting because
um
we've reduced the number of variables
from order D Squared to order d and
furthermore we've reduced the number of
possibilities for um the polynomial P
that describes the acceptance
probability uh we you get that it's not
just any polynomial it's in fact a
symmetric polynomial
so
by further reducing this polynomial to a
two variable polynomial
we're able to obtain the following lower
Bound for the recurrence term problem
that any algorithm
must use at least T over epsilonic
queries or a square root of deep queries
and we compare this to
um upper bound we get
of um T times root t
which uses the quantum amplitude of
amplification algorithm
we also apply our techniques to
entanglement entropy problem which we'll
recall is this side uh whether or not a
given state has entanglement entropy at
most a or at least 2A for some parameter
a
foreign
does not have
a full unitary symmetry it has some
symmetry which is a local unitary
symmetry that is a given state has a
high entanglement entropy if and only if
some tensor product unitary mutants are
being
applied to the state also has kind of
technological entropy
to exploit this low plug unitary
symmetry to show that the acceptance
probability
of a t query algorithm for the
entanglement entropy problem can be
written as
a symmetric polynomial in the
eigenvalues of rho
which is um the reduced density Matrix
of the State sign
using this theorem we're able to show
The Following lower bound that um
any Quantum algorithm for the integral
entropy problem
must use exponential of eight divided by
four queries
in particular
um we show also show a general
connection between the symmetries of the
property testing problem
and the properties of a polynomial that
encodes the acceptance probability for
any tester for this property
this relies on the the concept of
invariant rings that is studied in
abstract algebra and we leave the
details of this to our paper
finally uh we described an application
to property testing with Quantum groups
um in this model the tester receives
access to the unitary review and upon
the state that supposedly certifies that
you as a guest instance
we call this the eqma property testing
model in analogy to the qma complexity
class of problems that can be verified
efficiently by a polynomial size Quantum
circuit with access to applying
medium-sized uh proof state
this model motivates the question of
when on approves provide speedups and or
when they are useless
one advantage of the polynomial method
is that the polymer method enables us to
immediately approve lower bounds
in the on the property testing problems
that we study in the qma setting and we
State our lower bounds here for the
recurrence time problem and the
entanglement entropy problem on the
slide
these are quite similar to the the bqp
lower bounds except with the additional
parameter M which is the number of
qubits in the the witness
whoever qma is also really interesting
as the model definition can be modified
to study the power of different types of
quantum proofs
one such setting is the qma2 setting
where the verifier has access to two
unentangled groups that is
a proof state of the form psi-1 tensor
situ
where each of PSI 1 and PSI 2 are are
polynomial be sized
we note that qma is always contained in
Q A2 as a verifier can always want to
ignore one of the proofs and act as a
qma verifier
foreign
however
um
an oracle separation between Q and A and
qma2 has been a long-sending problem in
Quantum complexity Theory
in particular an oracle separation would
resolve watrouses and disentangular
injections
and fair Memorial the only complexity
classes that are known presently are
that qma2 is contained in NX and this is
appears to be a vast complexity Gap
qb2 also has some very interesting
properties such as um there's a fear of
by Aaron cenobl that states that there's
a qma2 protocol through freesat on in
variables where each proof state
contains
um square root of n qubits
this appears to be a quite
counter-intuitive as it seems as though
um
a linear number of qubits would be
necessary
and indeed
um
this is not believed to be true for Q a
assuming the exponential time hypothesis
our last contribution in this paper is
to describe a possible approach for the
qma versus human tooth problem
but we introduced the entangled Subspace
problem which is given Oracle access to
a unitary that encodes some Subspace
that's of CD tensor CD the check whether
or not there's a state in the s that is
either close to a product state or if
all states invests are far away from
being important
we show that this can be tested by
accumulate 2 verifier and conjecture
that cannot be tested by accumulator
in particular towards this conjecture we
show a lower bound against qcna which is
the subclass of q a that has a Quantum
verifier but a classical Witness
and additionally we present upper
observations about the integral Subspace
problem such as some observations about
average case versions of this problem
where um p is chosen randomly
the main problem left by this word is
the previous strong human lower
boundaries problem
um we observe that the problem has a
local unitary Symmetry and so we expect
our observations that connect symmetries
of a property testing problems to uh
lower bounds to be useful in this
setting
secondly
um
we do not have tight lower bounds for
some of our problems such as the
recurrence time problem introduced
earlier and plus it's interesting to
prove to see if our techniques can be
extended to prove tight lower balance
for this problem in the bqp and qma
settings
finally as all the problems that we
discuss have unitary or local unitary
symmetries it would be interesting to
investigate whether or not our methods
can be used for problems with other
types of synergies thank you for your
time